[Musique]
le 1er décembre 1959 le monde a décidé
que devrait exister un endroit sans
armes sans guerre sans frontières sans
exploitation de l'homme par l'homme
[Musique]
une communauté idéale de personnes
libres se livrant à des activités
pacifiques
[Musique]
salut
salut à tous comment ça va salut très
bien un endroit incroyable pour des gens
incroyables
alors même que les gens ici sont
finalement tout à fait ordinaire ce
n'est qu'après avoir vécu ici ne
serait-ce qu'une courte période que les
gens changent
cet endroit changent tous ceux qui s'y
rendent qu'est ce qu'il faut là quelque
chose à manger
il y à un vent très fort c'est beaucoup
mieux
c'est génial de voyager à travers le
monde il ya des gens bien partout pas
seulement chez nous
avec une façon de penser différentes une
couleur de peau différente une cuisine
différente
[Musique]
en fait je voudrais en rencontres et
autant que possible
beaucoup de langues différentes sont
parlé ici mais les gens se comprennent
tous très bien
[Musique]
certains parlent même aux animaux aux
oiseaux communie avec la nature ils
s'entendent et coexistent tous très bien
[Musique]
il n'y a rien de mal à avoir des rêves à
notre âge je pense vraiment que ses
beaux rêves sont une partie essentielle
tout à fait indispensable de notre vie
normale et du progrès parce qu'à partir
de tel rêve quelque chose de réel
pourrait prendre forme
je suis biologiste la biologie et
l'écologie sont mes domaines de travail
je ne suis pas à l'aise avec la façon
dont nous vivons sur cette planète
mon rêve est de nous rapprocher un peu
plus du moment où nous serons en mesure
de réparer au moins quelque chose que
tout exprès
la vie ici peut sembler insupportable le
vent et le froid pénètre jusqu'aux os
pas un seul arbre buissons ou brun
d'herbe juste un désert sans vie
attendez
je dois rien du tout
[Musique]
mais des gens vivent et travaillent ici
il marie même ils pensent tous être
investis d'une mission cruciale conduire
l'humanité sur la voie du progrès vers
la connaissance de la planète et de
l'univers
[Musique]
a enfin en terrain solide oui la vue est
absolument merveilleuse
c'est ça l'antarctique l'antarctique est
le continent le plus méridional de la
terre il est baignée par trois océans
[Musique]
c'est un no man's land d'une superficie
de 14 millions de kilomètres carrés
c'est aussi ici que la température la
plus basse connues sur la planète - 89,2
degrés a été enregistré
le pôle sud est probablement l'endroit
le plus inaccessible de la planète ou
presque
il existe encore ici en antarctique un
pôle d'inaccessibilité même la musique
est perçu différemment ici
[Musique]
en fait tout est différent des gens de
plus de 30 pays différents vivent
ensemble dans une communauté étroitement
soudée
[Musique]
l'antarctique est une exceptionnelle
communauté internationale il y a eu il y
a toujours beaucoup de collaborations la
beauté du travail de recherche en
antarctique c'est la motivation du
partage de ressources car vous ne pouvez
survivre seuls sur ce continent
[Musique]
il ya donc une sorte de culture d'entre
aide chacun dans son domaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
difficile de bien jouer
je veux bien sûr parce qu'il faut porter
des gants ce n'est pas très confortable
mais je suis sûr que mes doigts sont
déjà bleu à cause du froid
[Musique]
c'est notre groupe avec les explorateurs
russe c'était en 2001 à quelles bases
celles de billing lausanne
tout le monde ici sait qu'un chirurgien
passent l'hiver la station de recherche
russe bellinghausen il s'occupe de tous
les blessés
[Musique]
les chiliens ont un dentiste donc tout
le monde va à la base de frais pour les
soins dentaires
c'est un ventilateur pulmonaire
mécanique
c'est une opération est nécessaire on
peut la réaliser
tout est prêt je vous rends vire super
formidable
[Musique]
vont les gens là où il fait bon eh oui
la cuisine est bonne
[Musique]
un cuisinier c'est un m il y un bon
vieux au mot anglais pour cela master il
est autonome il doit savoir tout faire
boulangerie pâtisserie par exemple c'est
l'anniversaire de quelqu'un et il faut
organiser une fête pour cette personne
les chinois viennent chez les russes
pour goûter le bortsch les russes vont à
la salle informatique des chinois car
elle dispose de la connexion internet la
plus rapide de la péninsule antarctique
[Musique]
recherche scientifique collaboration et
respect voilà ce qui est permis en
antarctique c'est l'accord auquel les
peuples de la terre adhère depuis 60 ans
il n'y a rien de plus important que la
coopération en antarctique
vous savez le traité sur l'antarctique
est un espace de paix et aux sciences
donc c'est ouvert à tout le monde tout
chercheur qu'il veut travailler en
antarctique est le bienvenu pour
coopérer avec les autres tout cas
[Musique]
le 1er décembre 1959 à washington dc
douze pays ont signé le traité sur
l'antarctique qui est entrée en vigueur
le 23 juin 1961
depuis ce jour l'antarctique n'est pas
une nation
le déploiement militaire et les navires
de guerre sont interdits au dessous du
60e parallèle sud
en 1981 l'antarctique a été déclarée
zone exempte d'armes nucléaires ce qui
en fait une zone interdite aux navires à
propulsion atomique et aux centrales
nucléaires
[Musique]
l'arrivée en antarctique du navire de
recherche scientifique académique firent
de rohff ne peut signifier qu'une chose
un changement d'équipé des explorateurs
polaires russe à toutes les stations de
l'antarctique l'académique fiodorov
s'approche ensuite 12 3 5 3 canal
d'urgence 16 540 avoue nouveau lazare et
sky a ici académique fiodorov je vous
reçois 2 3 sur 5
vous me recevait avoue 65 après une
période de service de 11 mois certains
rentreront chez eux et d'autres
prendront leur place pour vivre et
travailler sur ce continent sévère
pendant près d'un an
comment vit-il cette période il se
plonge dans leur travail pensent à leur
maison bien sûr mais vivent avant tout
leurs rêves
[Musique]
de nos jours les gens vivent très bien
dans le monde que nous connaissons un
monde qui est absolument inefficace pour
ce qui est des ressources naturelles et
de la consommation énergétique
[Musique]
imaginez combien de chaleur d'énergie et
de travail humain il faut pour produire
un simple morceau de fer qui se trouve
quelque part sous ma maison et est en
train de rouiller
c'est délirant c'est inconcevable comme
gaspillage
[Musique]
on vient de prendre les échantillons
vient ici on sait dans les échantillons
ça fait partie du travail leur télé
votons délais
que coco en tant qu'écologiste je dois
aussi penser aux gens à nous car nous
faisons partie de l'écosystème
il ya beaucoup des ponts gecina sidi
quelques photos si tu peux presque une
sim assidi ça ressemble à des boules tu
sais comme les acides comme les acides
iwuy messina 6 10 90 % de ce que nous
produisons sont en fin de compte des
déchets ce ne sont pas des paroles en
l'air c'est vraiment comme ça le système
même de production de viande de poisson
de céréales et de vêtements ne
fonctionne pas bien
l'indication délicieuse le but n'est pas
de fils et partout des ampoules à
économie d'énergie
je te brûler la question est de
s'engager de faire en sorte que cette
ampoule fonctionne le plus longtemps
possible dans ma maison
[Musique]
pour le moment je suis plus intéressé
par les choses que je peux faire moi
même de mes propres mains
ça pourrait faire partie de quelque
chose de plus grand mais ce sera déjà un
pas en avant
d'ailleurs l'antarctique est un endroit
parfait pour ce genre de folie
[Musique]
difficile de comprendre ce qui attire
ces gens ici année après année comment
peuvent-ils supporter 11 mois de vie
monotone de paysage immuable avoir les
mêmes gens jour après jour
loin de la famille des amis
[Musique]
quand ils sont descendus ils étaient
heureux content leurs yeux brillent et
il était prêt à embrasser tout le monde
et rayonnait de joie
les yeux sont le miroir de l'âme et
leurs rames étaient ouverts elle était
illuminée c'est un tel plaisir de voir à
quel point les autres sont heureux
lorsqu'il rentre à la maison c'est juste
magnifique de les voir heureux pour 60%
des explorateurs polaires leur première
expédition et leur dernière pour les
autres c'est le contraire ils aspirent à
retourner en antarctique encore et
encore
pourquoi suis-je aller en antarctique
je ne m'en souviens pas je suis né avec
le rêve d'aller en antarctique je
suppose
[Musique]
quand j'ai vu un iceberg pour la
première fois en entendre parler est une
chose en voir est une autre quand vous
voyez disons un morceau de sucre géant
qui flotte
c'était quelque chose d'incroyable je me
suis dit plus jamais ça
alors je suis resté à la maison 4 ans
oui maman je serai avec vous à la maison
les enfants tout ça ok c'est bon bien ce
soir j'ai reçu un appel du service du
personnel j'ai immédiatement demandé
il faut que je fasse mes valises tout de
suite et voilà c'est tout juste en appel
ils disent aux jeux seraient heureux d'y
retourner mais j'aimerais pas me
retrouver avec des gens qui sont allés
auparavant
les gens ont peur que quelqu'un dise ici
je sais tout mieux que vous les gars
parce que j'ai déjà été ici donc
l'expérience ne compte pas
[Musique]
12 10 8 6 5 4 3 2 50 cm atterrissage
les scientifiques en antarctique
s'intéresse à tout absolument tout notre
planète traverse une période de
changement comprendre quels aspects de
ces changements font partie de cycles
naturels et être capable de distinguer
une influence humaine est cruciale pour
moi par exemple je suis géophysicienne
je prenais des mesures sismologiques les
gravitationnelle on observait le
mouvement des glaces et on faisait
également des mesures magnétique
nous étudions le champ magnétique
terrestre
comment ils se renforcent ou faibli
comment il a changé de direction et
aussi comment se forment les aurores
boréales en l'air est également examinée
il analyse sa composition et enregistre
la vitesse du vent l'eau la neige et la
glace sont également étudiés il y avait
alors un observatoire météorologique et
géophysique et en laboratoire de chimie
ont prélevé des échantillons de neige
c'était le début de mon travail actuel
parce que j'ai commencé à travailler
avec la base de données de 20 mn et puis
après ma thèse de doctorat s'est étendu
à d'autres sujets et s'est développée en
un domaine plus large et c'est ce que je
fais maintenant les pierres présente un
intérêt particulier à l'ogc nice est un
type de roche métamorphique est en fête
il ya si vous regardez de près vous
verrez des capsules ronde là dedans
elles ressemblent à des yeux c'est le
mot allemand pour oeil et aogo kim aris
et le type de roche
on étudie également le peu de soles
qu'il y a seul 1% de l'antarctique est
constitué de permafrost
nous allons effectuer une série d'
analyse chimique des analyses
isotopiques pour établir quelle était la
température en antarctique quand cette
glace était en formation
elles aideront à déterminer à quoi
ressemble et l'environnement ici il ya
mille ans les scientifiques accorde une
attention particulière à la flore et à
la faune de l'antarctique
[Musique]
pendant la période d'observation
la température a augmenté en hiver cinq
fois plus vite qu'en europe centrale et
cela eu de grandes conséquences pour les
pingouins
les manchots adélie ont besoin de glace
en hiver
la raison en est que sous la glace vive
de petites algues dont se nourrissent le
krill et des crustacés qui constitue à
leur tour la principale nourriture des
manchots donc s'il n'y a pas de glace il
n'y a pas de crise ce qui induit un
manque de nourriture pour les pingouins
qui sont alors obligés de se déplacer
plus au sud
dans ces glaces et seo l'antarctique
détient nombre de mystères du passé et
de l'avenir de notre planète
des scientifiques estiment que si cette
terre choisi de relever ses secrets nos
vies pour échanger
un peu votre rêve sept ans un nouvel
ordre social
un nouveau type de relations entre les
gens je ne vois rien de mal à cela
même s'il n'y a qu'une dizaine ou une
vingtaine d'une centaine ou un millier
de gens comme moi quelque chose de bon
pourrait en sortir
[Musique]
e
mais aucune recherche scientifique ne
serait possible sans quelque chose
d'essentiel
mais qu'est ce qui est essentiel sur ce
lointain continent sur l'essentiel ici
ce sont les gens des autres venant ici
vous devez faire face aux aspects
négatifs des autres et les autres
doivent faire face ou votre en étaient
25 personnes travaillent à la station
vostok seulement 10 à 12
il passe l'hiver ces bâtiments n'ont pas
vu la lumière du soleil depuis longtemps
ils sont complètement enneigée et on ne
peut sortir dehors que par un tunnel de
neige
un tel isolement a une influence sur les
relations au sein de l'équipe
j'aime les gens ici ce doit être des
gens bien parce que si vous n'êtes pas
quelqu'un de bien ce sera dur ici pour
vous bien sûr ce n'est pas le cas de
tout le monde
il y à de véritables vaut rien mais il y
en a peu je pense que c'est
principalement à cause des spécificités
de la vie ici de ce mode de vie très
particulier
vous devez toujours vous entraider d'une
manière ou d'une autre ça renforce
évidemment l'équipe ça unis les gens
[Musique]
et
le soleil brille de manière incroyable
le niveau d'ultraviolets est ici le plus
élevé au monde
et lorsque le rayonnement a réfléchi par
la neige il est encore plus fort sans
protection adéquate les yeux peuvent
être abîmée au point d'aboutir à la
cécité la peau du visage peut être brûlé
au point que des clubs se forment les
lèvres jusqu'à ce qu'elle se couvre de
croûtes sanglante
tout cela est dû à un trou dans la
couche d'ozone un grand trou a été
découvert ici en antarctique en 1985 et
cela a révolutionné notre conception de
l'atmosphère on pensait auparavant qu'il
y avait trop d'ozone que cela
empoisonnait notre biosphère et
provoquer un effet de serre
[Musique]
mais en travaillant ici des
scientifiques ont clarifié les choses
oui ce trou apparaît chaque hôte pour
terrifier l'humanité mais il disparaît
en décembre comme s'il n'avait jamais
existé
lorsque le trou est ouvert les rayons du
soleil pénètre facilement l'atmosphère
et à cause du réchauffement rapide de
l'air d'énormes masses d'air commence à
tourbillonner autour de l'antarctique
c'est ainsi que de violents cyclones se
forme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le navire de recherche académique
fjodorovs a livré et décharger toute sa
cargaison de carburant de machines
d'équipements scientifiques et de
provisions aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on
fait tous ceux dont la station de
recherche en antarctique vostok situé à
l'intérieur du continent sera chargé sur
des traîneaux et transportés par des
tracteurs ensuite ce traîneau à
chenilles entamera un long voyage
[Musique]
la colonne ne s'arrête pas deux équipes
la maintiennent en mouvement quand les
uns sont au volant les autres dorment
dans les compartiments lee il y avait
une fuite à la pompe
j'ai dû la remplacer il faisait moins 30
de -33 d'or
[Musique]
il ya toujours du vent là bas et ça
souffle toujours que dans une direction
avec un hurlement comme ça ça souffle
plus ou moins fortes
[Musique]
ils sont sur la route pendant deux à
trois semaines
le sol couverts de neige ressemble à la
mer mais ces vagues sont durs comme la
pierre et les remorques tang
[Musique]
les conducteurs qui peuvent conduire sur
ce terrain sans réveiller leurs
camarades sont les plus appréciés lors
de cette course j'ai appris à me coller
aux matelas par réflexe même en dormant
à m'accrocher à n'importe quelle surface
le véhicule est secoué tout le temps et
ce dès cet été le signe
quand massive avec tout ce bruit tout ce
mouvement je ne dormais pas plus vous
avez fini votre quart de travail et vous
ne pouvez pas dormir puis en autre quart
a lieu vous dormez un peu l'oeil nu
suivante est la troisième nuit vous
dormez déjà bien sur cette route
difficile et dangereuse tout peut
arriver en haut du dôme de glace de
l'antarctique
l'atmosphère est pauvre en oxygène en
conséquence de quoi les moteurs call et
tombe en panne il faut les réparer sur
place par moins 50 degrés celsius
celui-ci quelque chose a lieu dans l'
iss là haut on peut envoyer de l'aide si
quelque chose arrive sous l'eau il est
aussi possible de leur apporter de
l'aide mais nous nous ne pouvons compter
que sur nous mêmes et il n'y a pas de
temps à perdre
chaque membre de l'expédition c'est
qu'ils doivent continuer à avancer quoi
qu'il arrive
s'ils n'atteignent pas la station
personne ne pourra passer l'hiver à
vostok et la station mourra la raison
pour laquelle la france utilise des
véhicules à chenilles pour ces
traversées et la capacité de ces
véhicules à transporter des charges très
lourdes il faut comprendre que le convoi
qui va chaque année de la côte à la
station concordia est le seul moyen d'y
livrer tout le nécessaire
il s'agit d'environ 5000 tonnes de
cargaison chaque année c'est énorme
bravo ingénieurs allemands qui ont conçu
cette merveilleuse machine
c'est un modèle polaire il a été conçu
ou plutôt modifier spécifiquement pour
l'antarctique
il est plus ou moins adaptés à ces rudes
conditions
[Musique]
ces chercheurs vont parcourir près de
3000 kilomètres en avion transpolaires
et resterons ici jusqu'à l'été
antarctique
[Musique]
où
la neige au coeur de l'antarctique à une
propriété étonnante lorsque la
température descend en dessous de -55
elle se transforme en sable de neige sec
si un avion atterrit sur cette surface
c'est ce qui se réchauffe instantanément
à cause du frottement et se soude à la
piste c'est pourquoi les avions ne pas
voler à vostok contre mi-décembre et
début février
à peine deux mois par an le reste du
temps les chercheurs sont complètement
coupées du monde
[Musique]
on
nous
[Musique]
pour l'approvisionnement en eau de la
station rostock on utilise de la neige
[Musique]
la base se trouve à plus de 3500 mètres
au dessus du niveau de la mer
à cette altitude même les plus costauds
se fatigue vite en raison du faible
niveau d'oxygène
chaque fois que vous allez à vos stocks
ces différences ces trois premiers jours
sont toujours différents parfois vous
vous couchez épuisé parfois vous vous
mettez au travail dès le premier jour
bien sûr vous ne pouvez pas manié la
pelle comme vous le faites à la maison
en fait quelques mouvements pour jeter
la neige que vous avez besoin de
respirer prendre votre temps réfléchir
puis vous recommencez les conditions
sont vraiment extrême est la température
moyenne en décembre et en janvier tombe
en dessous de -30 et en hiver et il
arrive qu'ils fassent moins 80 la
pression atmosphérique et 40% inférieure
et il y a moins d'oxygène dans l'air les
maux de tête les douleurs articulaires
et les segments données sont des
symptômes d'acclimatation
cela peut prendre un mois pour que votre
organisme s'adapte c'est l'hypoxie tout
le monde a une réaction différente c'est
le mal de l'altitude
on peut ne pas s'y habituer il faut s'y
adapter c'est tout ça peut vous affecter
soudainement même en plein milieu de
votre mission divers la russie ou plutôt
l'union soviétique à l'époque a mis en
place la station vostok car c'était
l'endroit le plus éloigné des côtes en
arctique
c'était l'endroit le plus inaccessible
dans un sens l'union soviétique vous les
montrer comme elle était capable de
faire face à des conditions extrêmes
donc au début je dirais que c'était un
projet plutôt politique et non pas
scientifique
aujourd'hui c'est différent c'est avant
tout scientifique
tout l'antarctique est recouvert d'une
calotte glaciaire dont l'épaisseur peut
atteindre 4 km c'est suffisant pour
couvrir toute la planète d'une couche de
glace de 50 mètres d'épaisseur
les géologues appelle ça arrive c'est
une formation géologique lorsque la
croûte terrestre déchirait une énorme
fissure se forme
voilà ce que c est cela qui est apparue
ici quand et dans quelles conditions
personne ne le sait on a pu se former
avant ou après la glaciation il ya des
roches sédimentaires de ceux là qui est
il y à de l'eau au dessus
fait intéressant sa surface n'est pas
horizontale comme c'est le cas avec les
lacs normaux elle est incliné
le lac vostok a été l'une des plus
grandes découvertes géographiques de la
seconde moitié du 20e siècle est les
chercheurs soupçonnaient depuis
longtemps qu'il y avait un lac de la
taille de l'europe sous la base russe
le lac sous-glaciaire vos stocks
existent depuis plusieurs millions
d'années
mais pour l'atteindre il faut percer la
glace dit atmosphérique formées par la
neige tombée en antarctique depuis des
millénaires
[Musique]
selon une théorie le lac est apparue
parce que la calotte glaciaire a fondu
sous la pression de son propre poids et
une autre suggère que le lac a toujours
existé avant même la glaciation de
l'antarctique que la calotte glaciaire
l'a tout simplement fermé la calotte
glaciaire en antarctique se compose de
la glace qu'on appelle atmosphérique et
la classe et formées à partir de
précipitations solide ce qui tombe à la
surface se transformant progressivement
glace sans que de l'onuci un produit à
la fin du xxème siècle ont eu lieu les
premières tentatives d'atteindre le lac
en forant les kilomètres de glace qui le
recouvrent sous la base de stock
la couche de cette glace atmosphérique
se termine à une profondeur de 3500 38 m
[Musique]
le forage au puy 5 g 1 a commencé en
les membres soviétique français et
américain de l'exposition conjointe vers
la station vostok et ont tous pris par
[Musique]
mon travail est liée aux études du
climat passé en antarctique
on obtient des carottes de glace pendant
le forage elle mesure environ 10 cm de
diamètre et peuvent atteindre trois
kilomètres de là
des chercheurs de divers pays fort les
glaces de l'antarctique et ils ont tous
leur propre méthode
mais seuls les foreurs russes ont réussi
à atteindre la limite inférieure de la
glace et l'eau du lac
apparemment on n'a pas encore inventé le
moyen de prélever des échantillons d'eau
du lac sans le contaminer et sans
introduire des micro organismes
[Musique]
jusqu'à présent nous n'avons aucun moyen
de savoir s'il ya de la vie dans l'eau
la plus ancienne de la terre mais les
paléoclimatologues ont trouvé du
matériel précieux pour leurs études
la glace est la seule archives ou a pu
être stockées l'historique de la
température de la terre et la
composition de l'atmosphère à
différentes époques
nous pouvons examiner la glace et en
découvrir la composition en particulier
la concentration de co2 en mesurant le
niveau de co2 on découvre sa
concentration dans l'atmosphère au cours
des huit cent mille dernières années
c'est précisément à m donc on va
découper ici ici l'analyse de cette
glace a donné des résultats
scientifiques qui nous aide à comprendre
le climat sur notre planète il y a des
centaines de milliers d'années voire de
millions d'années comment grâce à de
minuscules bulles d'air conservés dans
la glace pendant des millions d'années
la neige qui tombe sans cesse se
solidifie sous son propre poids et se
transforme progressivement en glace et
voici ce qui se passe c'est border entre
les cristaux de glace se renferme avec
le temps et il se transforme alors en
bulles s'être posé le pied ainsi chaque
bulle n'est rien de moins qu'un
échantillon de l'atmosphère d'une autre
époque femme devenue atmosphère
grâce à ces études les chercheurs savent
que des gaz à effet de serre le dioxyde
de carbone et le méthane se sont
plusieurs fois accumulé dans
l'atmosphère conduisant à des
réchauffements climatiques
des centaines de milliers d'années plus
tard leur niveau diminuer à nouveau
déclenchant des périodes glaciaires
voulons en apprendre plus sur le
changement climatique majeur qui a eu
lieu il ya environ un million d'années
ça demeure une énigme en quelque sorte
nous ne savons pas vraiment ce qui s'est
passé on suppose que le dioxyde de
carbone dans l'atmosphère en a été
responsable nous voulons vérifier le
niveau de dioxyde de carbone dans
l'atmosphère il ya un million d'années
le réchauffement climatique auquel nous
assistons aujourd'hui n'est-il qu'une
période de l'histoire climatique de la
planète se mouiller ou partiellement
responsable de ces bouleversements
ce sont des questions auxquelles les
paléontologues tente de trouver les
réponses en antarctique
pas qu'un jour je vais vous montrer
quelques photos que nous avions prises
en antarctique
celle ci a été prise il ya 25 ans at il
fourni c'est nous avec des étudiants un
petit groupe d'étudiants à la base de
belinga salle on y comptait les
pingouins et les phoques entre deux
roues
[Musique]
les chercheurs de tous les pays
représentés en antarctique poursuivre
des objectifs purement scientifique mais
les politiques ont un autre but
c'est ce qu'ils appellent la présence la
qualité de la présence sur le sixième
continent est un symbole de la force
d'une nation et de sa capacité à influer
sur l'avenir de l'antarctique
[Musique]
les etats unis l'australie la france
l'allemagne la chine le japon l'inde le
chili et d'autres pays ont des bases en
antarctique plus de 50 pays y sont
présents et ils sont tous signataires du
traité sur l'antarctique
[Musique]
maintenant il faut trouver un bon
endroit
justin voilà juste ici le moment de
vérité approche
le traité de 1959 expire dans moins de
30 ans c'est merveilleux c'est
absolument fantastique que ces tensions
n'est pas d'importance dans la
communauté scientifique
des problèmes peuvent surgir une urgence
médicale où les conditions météo font
obstacle aux études scientifiques dans
tel ou tel domaine
et c'est là que la coopération a lieu on
se demande comment s'entraider
les autres problématiques n'ont aucun
impact sur le travail de recherche dans
les bases antarctique
cet exemple illustre la manière dont la
communauté internationale peut se réunir
comment nous pouvons surmonter les
problèmes et travailler ensemble
[Musique]
pour le moment tous les explorateurs
polaires respecte les règles adoptées il
ya 60 ans la seule activité autorisée et
la recherche
[Musique]
prenons par exemple mon oiseau préféré
le lab antarctique
alors nous regardons la population
suivons la situation écologique et aussi
la migration est curieusement nous avons
constaté que les oiseaux migrent en
hiver dans deux directions vers
l'atlantique nord et vers le nord de
l'océan pacifique
mais les habitants du coin ne sont pas
toujours satisfaits de l'attention qui
leur est portée
[Musique]
il y avait des pingouins quand nous
sommes sortis pour une promenade les
pingouins marché nous marquions à côté
d'eux c'était des petits manchots adélie
et il y avait une forte pente sur la
colline était en haut il était debout et
regarder autour de lui comme ça mes
camarades ont continué et je suis resté
environ 5 ou 6 mètres derrière eux et je
regardais ce pas loin la pauvre mon dieu
il y avait un éboulis 5 mètres en haut
de la colline et 5 m en bas de la
colline une pente vraiment raide je me
suis dit comment es-tu monter là haut tu
ne pourras pas descendre tout seul je ne
pouvais pas l'abandonner là vous
comprenez ce pauvre oiseau dont j'ai
grimpé sur cette colline et il a senti
que quelque chose se trame et que ça ne
sentait pas bon et il a commencé à me
crier dessus et mois à temps il seconde
je viens t d alors je suis monté là haut
mais j'avais un peu peur de descendre
j'étais tout de même à 5 mètres de haut
alors je les saisies sous les ailes bien
sûr il a commencé à se tortiller
j'ai fini par descendre avec ce pingouin
entre les mains et tous les autres
manchots continue à marcher leur file
s'étendait sur presque plus d'un
kilomètre où ils allaient tous alors je
lui ai posé par terre ce petit manchot
voilà c'est tout j'ai dit ça y est mon
petit il continué je suppose qu'il
manque de lait
[Musique]
au bon dieu
alors j'ai décidé de m'éloigner et vous
savez quoi
il a recommencé à graviers à la pente
plus tard j'ai compris que c'était une
sentinelle un veilleur
[Musique]
voilà une histoire pour vous
c'est ma maison c'est calme paisible ici
j'aimerais que les gens soient plus
comme en antarctique
si le cordiaux plus sincères plus ouvert
tiens c'est un endroit extraordinaire
en arrivant ici vous sentez que vous
avez trouvé votre place dans l'univers
ce sont très très petit
comment faire face à tout cela
heureusement il y a les vacances
gras les sapins ne pousse pas ici on à
billère à quelqu'un en demoiselle de
neige il n'y a pas de frontières ici
vous pouvez aller où vous voulez il y a
les chinois non loin la station chinoise
les australiens sont tout près les
indiens aussi et puis qu'est-ce que tu
croyais tout et comme il faut je ne
parle pas un mot d'anglais ils ne
parlent pas russe et vie nous entendons
très bien
[Musique]
c'est au milieu de l'hiver qu'a lieu la
plus grande fête en antarctique
tout le monde la célèbre peu importe le
pays d'origine
la fête du milieu de l'hiver signifie
que la moitié de la saison s'est écoulé
et que le retour à la maison approche
[Musique]
les américains sont inventifs
ils ont décidé que tout le monde devrait
fêter le milieu de l'hiver ensemble plus
on est de fous les i en antarctique
winter film festival dit le wsj
le festival du film antarctique approche
il est prévu pour le premier week-end
d'août à la base américaine mc murdo
mcmurdo et la plus grande station
antarctique
c'est une petite ville avec une
population de près de 1500 habitants
merci qui le programme du festival
comprend deux parties la première est la
catégorie ouverte
les participants envoient leurs films
amateurs de tous genres sur n'importe
quel sujet la seule restriction est la
durée le film ne doit pas dépasser 5
minutes
pourquoi seulement 5 à cause du bas
débit des connexions internet en
antarctique
[Musique]
la deuxième catégorie concerne les films
réalisés en seulement 48 heures le
vendredi les organisateurs du festival
annonce les règles et le lundi tous les
participants envoient leurs oeuvres qui
sont montrés à mcmurdo et le jury rend
son verdict il ya plusieurs catégories
comme lors des festivals de cinéma
meilleur film meilleur acteur meilleur
scénario meilleure photographie
et il ya également un prix du public
[Musique]
je vais tuer
tous les habitants de l'antarctique vive
conformément à la loi les uns suivent la
loi de la nature les autres respectent
les dispositions du traité sur
l'antarctique
traitée dans le cadre du traité de
le protocole sur la protection de
l'environnement a été adopté au début
des années 90 tout ce protocole
environnementale concerne notre
comportement face à l'environnement
il explique surtout l'exploitation
minière la protection de la faune la
protection de zones qui présentent un
intérêt scientifique particulier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ici le ventilateur fonctionne créant une
pression négative pour qu'il y ait un
courant d'air
donc la fumée ne passe pas par les porcs
elle passe par le système de filtration
avant d'être rejetées dans l'atmosphère
[Musique]
selon les règles tous pays se trouve en
antarctique ne doit laisser que des
terres vierges derrière lui c'est ce que
les explorateurs font chaque année
lorsqu'il se prépare au changement
d'équipé et qu'un grand navire arrive
ils brûlent tout ce qui peut être brûlés
le verre et la ferraille sont collectées
pour être expédiées ailleurs nous allons
remplir ce baril de tesson ça prendra
beaucoup moins d espace dans le
conteneur plus tard la ferraille et le
verre seront chargés dans un conteneur
qui sera transporté vers le navire par
tracteur et par hélicoptère
le véhicule blindé est tombé en panne
mais cela ne m'a pas arrêté les
problèmes techniques ne sont pas une
excuse pour moi donc j'ai transporté
toutes les ordures sur les épaules
les règles sont strictes en antarctique
il ya un protocole avec des annexes tout
y est précisé ce qui est interdit ce
qu'on ne peut pas introduire dans la
région animaux et plantes produits
chimiques ou matériaux spéciaux si tous
les pays prenait cela au sérieux
il ne fait aucun doute que ce serait
beaucoup mieux pour l'écologie pour
les gens installer ces panneaux à la
base d'un oeil mayer pour indiquer la
distance qui les sépare de leurs maisons
par exemple rima à vannes se trouve à
14000 25 km d'ici twenty five killers
menace
chaque station antarctique a des repères
de ce type
c'est un symbole de la maison est un
discret signe de la nationalité de la
station
[Musique]
il
il ya des petites différences ici par
exemple vous pouvez boire de l'eau de
n'importe quel flac comme un homme
préhistorique sans nuire à votre santé
il ya beaucoup de petites choses comme
ça
le climat rigoureux entrave la
colonisation de l'antarctique mais à
l'avenir s'il fait plus chaud le
continent le plus méridional pourrait
être peuplée
nous ne pouvons pas ignorer l'intérêt
politique des états à avoir des stations
en antarctique
il ya un intérêt économique pour le
tourisme en antarctique
je pense que c'est important de fixer
des limites
mais l'existence du traité sur
l'antarctique ne signifie pas que les
pays qui l'ont ratifié ont renoncé à
leurs revendications territoriales sur
le continent et les régions voisines
[Musique]
les revendications de certains pays sont
énormes
[Musique]
la beauté du traité de l'antarctique
c'est que toutes les nations qui ont des
revendications territoriales les mèdes
complètement de côté et comme vous le
savez certains territoires mentionnés
dans ces revendications se chevauchent
tout mais tout cela n'a pas d'importance
puis grâce qu'on consacre tout et ford
aux recherches scientifiques
il serait vraiment dommage que les
valeurs inscrites dans ce traité les
valeurs d'une communauté de citoyens
libres engagée uniquement dans la
recherche et le progrès scientifique
sombre un jour dans l'oubli il devrait y
avoir une place sur terre pour une
véritable liberté une réelle égalité et
une fraternité humaine
[Musique]